[Musique]
Mesdames et Messieurs,
je vous présente
la huitième merveille du monde
[Musique]
la seule et unique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour les chiots
tournez-vous, laissez-moi vous regarder,
j'aurai raison  ici, quand tu reviendras,
Pinocchio court partout
sans conscience, peux-tu imaginer que les
ennuis dans lesquels il va se trouver ne voudraient pas
que sur ma conscience tout le monde
qui est quelqu'un veut être quelqu'un mais
je veux être réel pourquoi diable voudrais-tu
être réel quand tu peux être
célèbre
peut vraiment changer une personne pinocks
oh ce qui se passe jiminy ressemble à
une sorte de magie féerique
sur le nez si vous me demandez
[Musique]
vous